[Music]
hello and welcome to my new show kill
yourself for viewers episode 1 there is
no show there is snow challenge I'm just
going to eat a bunch of hot sauces we
discovered that it doesn't the content
is irrelevant on YouTube these days it's
just all about the titles so I thought
we'd live up to the title and in my life
I've been doing YouTube for 6 years I
think you'd think I'm above this at this
point I don't want to do this I
genuinely don't want to zoom II know my
face I don't want to [ __ ] do this
this is stupid this is dumb oh my is
this to challenge let's give you a nice
easy hot sauce fast
oh I wonder what it's time to eat some
chicken
usually it's good I liked it next
lootcrate hot sauce oh I hope this one
is the one that does the trick now you
know this is spicy because it doesn't
all come out you know it only comes up a
little drips was this made out of [ __ ]
there's not I got nothing
this video has been brought by a little
crime next lootcrate hot showers oh I
will say that I'm starting to develop a
little bit of a spicy mom how well this
one doesn't smell oh Jesus how low all
right let's get it all up in there oh my
god that was so unnecessary
who bought things
I mean it's fuzzy oh this one this one
came it came a little later the poison
one we poisoned one - this stuff is
horrendous
[Music]
you remember this guy's kill me this my
poem in hospital crazy
you actually did it yeah my god yeah you
poisoned me next the ultimate hot sauce
challenge where's that one give me now
all right here we go
oh Jesus
you guys fed me this [ __ ] oh dude this
will kill me this is not funny I will
die for the views
oh my god I'm shaking look at me morning
the sauce is very hot use that your
Omega Oh Oh No Oh
[Music]
oh is it that fast is it that fast
why don't you warn me about the last one
before even happening you were drinking
it from the bottle it's time to review
the little crack let's unbox it first of
all we have a t-shirt from fantasy
fantastic beasts fantastic beasts have
you guys watched a movie did you like it
I'm not a big Harry Potter fan I am like
I'm gonna do and I'm an adult I'm over
it okay we got Doctor Strange figured
I'm gonna keep this in the box but it's
really cool and it looks cute it's cool
we have a game of Thrones diary I think
it is the night is dark and full of
terrors just like my ass it's full of
terrorists right now it said it's a
diary it's a diary you want to start
right now dear diary my ass is on fire
we got a pin alright this one unlock
something epic if you go to Luke Craig
dot-com such pins it feels like an alien
baby is inside of me there we go we've
got a pin
we got a magazine Big Trouble in Little
China escape from New York that's cool
and then we have the explanation of the
artifacts so yeah it's a pretty cool
look rate as always it's really fun to
get a little crate every month and just
get a bunch of cool stuff you know for a
good value good
if you like to collect figurines blue
crate is like a must
next one theme is revolution and you
order not before the 19th to get that
one
go to Luke Raycom size appears enter the
code pin so you get 10% off you guys
know the drill I really appreciate that
you guys check this out I think I need
20-30 minutes